what's up y'all i'm here hanging out
with vin diesel
um well you're a kid of 1980s new york
city
so yeah let's end this with a quick game
of 80s this or that
are you ready yes okay hot pockets
or pop secret oh my god i mean there's
really just one option but fine
okay um
did did i do i definitely didn't do hot
pockets
you did it is that the southern thing oh
yes okay
i've never met a person in my life that
ate hot pockets oh you have now brother
[Applause]
she's like go ahead girl look i grew up
on cheap poor people food
so yeah i definitely we didn't do hot
pockets
my mom didn't have a microwave oh we it
was one of those kind of homeopathic
oh gosh kind of things we had wheat
bread we were then it was whole grain
bread it was
oh gosh okay that was we grew up in
different oh yes
no soda allowed oh yeah no i lived on dr
pepper
there's a reason how i ended up here
[Laughter]
so pac-man or galaga um
i was a pac-man oh pac-man but i i'm
gonna tell you
this is you're not gonna bring it and i
should confess um
there was a bowling alley and there was
a pac-man machine
and my i had a friend that taught me how
to tape
a quarter you what two
things you can put and you could pull it
out and we used to go and so we
ended up playing pac-man all night
because we were able to here's the thing
i don't think that's stealing i think
that's clever
that's collaborative i think that's you
know what that's being resourceful
yeah i'm recording that's wrong i played
a hundred games yeah that's okay
you you cheated the system fairly i
think yes cheated the system fairly do
you like that
okay so parachute pants or acid wash
jeans
i'm southern so okay i have to go with
acid wash
you have to go acid wash i guess i have
to go as you watch because i wasn't
doing parachute
um okay flock of seagulls hair or mullet
i mean you know
which 80s is this white i joke i'm
joking
you just didn't do flock of scenes i was
doing i was doing run dmc
i was great okay okay okay i told you
break dancing
okay okay or not mullet either neither
no not mullet either mullet is
definitely where i'm from
gotcha okay matchbox cars or micro
machines
matchbox yeah me too yeah all the way my
this is a hardware
michael jackson or prince that's hard
this is a big debate for people it's too
big a debate because both of them
represent
so much to try to
it's it would be blasphemy too not me i
go prince i like both but prince
i i liked a bit more don't beat me up no
i'm not gonna
i just want to say wait a minute um okay
let's let's think about this let's think
about that is there a prince without
a michael jackson princess does
something incredible
he he's a true crossover artist he's
hitting all demographics he's hitting
everybody
because he's coming out with something
reminiscent of
uh jimi hendrix he's playing
he's doing what jimi hendrix was doing
in the 60s
but what michael jackson did
almost pre-hip-hop is profound what he
does for black music
in the beginning is mind-boggling
oh i think it's great okay here's a
really hard one i'm throwing it in
that's right
whitney or mariah what
what that's hard
whitney or mariah here's the thing i'm
actually pleading the fifth on that one
oh come on you got it what would you
guys think mariah or whitney
you don't want to do it do you wait wait
oh we got a bunch of wings got some
whitney's
got some weight okay okay okay
but mariah is amazing with the amazing i
will say nobody gives her the credit as
like all those hits were written from
her hand
that is incredible yeah think of the
number one she has had in her career
because there's a billion
even if they're not number ones they're
just great songs like it's an amazing
thing she was
such a contribution to writer yeah
anyway
well thank you for dropping by i like
playing games you're talking about this
yeah oh we can talk about music i will
talk for hours i love your upbringing i
want to talk more about that i want your
family information
i want you to hear all my music i know
well vin diesel
everybody f9 is in theaters this friday
everybody go see
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help